what we're gonna be going over today is
typescript what is it how to get started
we're gonna be even talking about the TS
link config and setup and we're gonna be
talking about the major parts of
typescript so that you know what to
expect in what it all contains so what
is typescript and why should we use it
superset of JavaScript it was built by
Microsoft I so it's being maintained by
Microsoft it's an open source project
more or less so you have a lot of the
community contributing it to it it's one
of Microsoft's open source items that
they they tend they they now are going
in open source direction which is pretty
cool at the end of the day what you get
back is regular JavaScript one of the
benefits to writing typescript as it
tends to be less error-prone we're
trying to apply static types to a
dynamically typed language and that
eliminates amer while yeah the concise
it's adding a little bit more
development time now he could argue that
development time is made up because it
lends code to be more readable and thus
more maintainable as time and time goes
on we have seen as developers so what
are we going to be covering well we're
going to showcase how to get started how
to assign types on variables how to
assign return types on functions we're
going to be talking about classes a
little bit although this is more that's
more of an es6 item we're gonna be
talking about string enums and number in
ohms we're also going to be talking
about interfaces intersection types
briefly about access modifiers and then
we're going to be talking about how to
set up TS lint so that if you are doing
typescript any want your code to to be
more readable and maintainable how you
can make sure that it's even better in
adhering to the latest standards so
that's what we're gonna be diving into
let's go ahead and jump right in
[Music]
all right so to get started in
typescript first thing you're gonna want
to have as a node installed if you don't
already you can use the current or the
latest it doesn't really matter whatever
works best for you it's all gonna work
and then from there well I'll be using
the Visual Studio code text editor you
can use whichever one you want but often
times people ask me what text editor I
prefer what I use this is what I use for
quite a few reasons I like the
extensions I think it's very clean then
intellisense is great in it and they
also have a debugging tool though I
don't use it very often so to get
started with typescript the first thing
that you need to do now that you have
known install just go ahead and run this
command I'll be using git bash if you
have another terminal you can use that
as well it doesn't really matter so
we're gonna install typescript globally
that's what this G is that's basically
just gonna mean that we're gonna have
access to the typescript commands moving
forward in our application this will
take just a second and let's go ahead
and open up our text adder and get
started alright so now that we have a
project open let's go ahead and create a
new file here to create a typescript
file all you have to do is instead of
creating an javascript file with the Jas
file extension we're going to be using
ATS in this case we're just gonna call
it example that TS now we have access to
typescript essentially now with Ariel
compiler or not that that's a whole
nother story but let's talk about you
know how we might use typescript for
instance in a very basic way in
JavaScript when we were potentially
create an array like so we'll call this
example we would then go and set this
array and we could have maybe some
numbers in it now the JavaScript itself
is gonna say hey I see this is an array
no big deal but you see now when we
hover over this it actually is
inheriting a type here of a number array
an array of numbers right now this is
called implicit typing where
when we're instantiating an object it's
going to look at it and if it can
inherit its type
there's also explicit typing where you
can say look I just want to actually
tell it exactly that this is going to be
a number array or perhaps it is going to
be an array of several things including
bullying's right so true and you'll
start to see right now the power of type
scripts were hey this is supposed to be
a number array we have instantiated the
type of saying look cannot you can get
this air here saying look you're trying
to do something to a number array that
isn't a number and one way that we can
modify this is to add a or property as
well as a use any and we'll talk about
what that is right now okay so sometimes
because of the nature of JavaScript when
we're dealing with dying a dynamically
typed language we're trying to make it a
little bit more static and start
assigning types is we'll have a race
where we may not have all the same data
type so one way that we can handle that
and this is with input and output we can
use the or operator in our case here
it's just a single pipe like so and then
we'd say number or boolean array right
now what this does here is to say hey we
are expecting an array it could be
number values it could be boolean values
either one but it couldn't be for
instance a string value right we're
throwing in something like that that's
not going to break it because those
types don't exist in this array now
let's go ahead and just get rid of this
and there's this any property I want to
talk about as well where any
essentially is the way of doing the
old-school JavaScript to a degree right
so all we're saying here is that this is
an array the values and it could be
anything we can also go ahead and assign
any directly and say look this may
change this may not be good this may be
a down the road you know if this was a
let this may actually go and become a
string and that would be okay in our
instance because we have said that is of
type any now if we said this was an in
ear
ray we'd get an air here and say look
this is not assignable you can't make a
array a string it just doesn't make
sense a week we don't want that and
that's the power of types to give you an
idea of hey how to prevent things like
that it's also going to stop you from
doing sort of crazy things if you're
caught up in the moment where you're
like hey I want to do an example dot map
then you return an array and you can do
some stuff right but if you try to call
map let's say let's say we actually
typed this all out element blah blah
blah right and we write here we return
you know element +1 or something right
and let's say this was a number array
right now that would work and we'll go
ahead and get rid of that boolean so we
could get a new value here so the x2 and
we instead say you know what I want to
change this year to a string I'm gonna
say this is a string and I set this
equal to an empty string you're gonna
catch this air here where it say hey say
right right there is no map map does not
exist on type string it only exists on
type object so what happens here is we
don't have to wait for our code to run
and compile and then you know hopefully
this function fires off and then we get
a console.log air our Visual Studio code
and the intellisense and typescript is
intelligent enough to tell you hey we
have an error let's look at what
happened here in regards to our types
and be able to fix it so that we don't
have to have those errors go into the
code now so far we've talked about
assigning types to variables but you can
also assign types to functions as well
right so let's say we have a function
called
add and it has a number one and a number
and what we want to do is return num1
plus num2 so not only can we assign it
on variables assigned types on various
it's going to zoom this in a little bit
we can also go ahead and assign it on
parameters where we are expecting a
number here and we are expecting a
string here
for instance maybe we're gonna move it
to you know a number or a string so we
now can assign that but not only that we
can say in this function we expect it to
return a number throwing a colon on here
as well so now this function is a lot
more detailed it gives you a better idea
of it's more descriptive in terms of
what this function is actually supposed
to do and sort of the type metadata here
if you wanna look at that way and we
have some checks in here so where if we
say hey let's return as a string it's
gonna say you know hold up hold up Dylan
this type number is not assignable
string because this isn't working here
so maybe you'd go in and you'd say you
know what let me couldn't I need this as
a number thanks for reminding me and now
I'm gonna convert it to a string so you
have that additional detail to a
function as well checks dry cleaner more
descriptive code that's easier to read
and maintain are one of the great things
about typescript is everything that
we've talked about is optional in
typescript it's just another way of
types are optional now you can write in
the TS linen and well showcase TS lint
in a little bit later how we might be
able to make it not optional if you
wanted to but by default
typescript is optional which means
everything we're doing you don't have to
do it's additional and I think you
should because it's shown to be better
code in terms of less airs going in
production but what you need to remember
is typescript is just a superset of
JavaScript it's just JavaScript
to the next level essentially and so say
we wanted to compile this down and
that's what would happen typically
you'll be working with like web pack and
a production environment and it would
just take your type script files and
compile them the JavaScript when it does
your build that goes out and is actually
being used in production and so in our
case you know our production application
is just our example here so how might we
manually do this so that we could see
hey I actually want to see that it is
just JavaScript that's happening here
and nothing nothing crazy we're just
assigning some additional data to Djoser
well we can use this TS c command which
you'll have if you finish installing
it types is the typescript package we
did earlier and then you name the file
right so in our example here we would do
example we're already in this folder
using our terminal here dot TS and
you'll see a second later we now have
this example J's file notice how there's
no types
notice how nothing has really changed
except the fact that we removed our
types from this and it has compiled it
to something that the browser your
browser knows and can work with so keep
that in mind is what we're writing in
typescript is we're adding additional
things to provide context for
development purposes to write cleaner
and better code but at the end of the
day javascript itself is a static ly
typed language that doesn't fully
understand a lot of the more
complexities when it comes to types and
object-oriented programming so you can
see this is as to me Tucker is very
readable but even more readable when it
compiles just down to JavaScript so
let's say for whatever reason you don't
want to create a paid typescript file
and you're not ready to make it so you
just want to do maybe some type checking
in your code what we could do here is we
can use this slash slash and go ahead
and throw at TS - check you'll notice
there's some other ones there's ignore
that essentially lets you ignore type
checking on that there is I don't even
what no check does I don't ignore that
but TS check here and this will say hey
let me just do a check to see if there's
any errors in your code right here so
let's say that we wanted to we had a
number for instance or we said hey let y
equal 5 and then normally you'd say yeah
let's go ahead and map that and that's
what we want to do we want to map
something and then
I have an element's here don't want to
return true or something like that and
it's a a does not max on type number the
only reason that shows up is because we
have our at TS check here to say hey
treat this javascript file as a type for
a file so that we can at least make some
checks that go along with it it's not
going to add more to the readability of
the code which is equally important but
is the very least is gonna say hey are
there any clear heirs and to in this
moment guys if you're writing JavaScript
I would encourage you to have this on
here so that you can sort of you know
see hover over this and say look map
does not exist on type number you're
like oh let me let it click in a little
bit why that is and you might you might
pick up a few things that way so that's
TS check which i think is really
important so emails are something that's
new to JavaScript and we're let's say we
wanted to store a set of data that
reference something and like we'd want
it to be the same throughout the
application one way that we might be
able to do that is with a number or a
string enum we're gonna go ahead and
create a a new file here and we're just
gonna call this example dot enum dot TS
and we're going to export here a enum
and this that we're gonna what are we
gonna call this we'll call these art
numbs you know and what's gonna have in
here is let's go ahead and call this
number one and you'll notice that by
typically when you're dealing with enums
it's going to be an all capped enum name
as well as all cap properties and so
we'll call this number one and then
we'll call this num too and what this is
going to be able to do if we go ahead
and import this into our type script
file here and this is what we call this
our nomes enum import known genome from
example you know now we'll have access
to it right so what this is gonna do is
say look whenever we have our whenever
we instantiate numsy namnam you know
num1 this is essentially going to be
equal to one and this one is essentially
going to be equal to two excuse me I
went off the trail there this is
actually zero on one because we never
start anything at one and two I was like
that's weird why did I say that but
you'll see here that this is essentially
zero and one now we are studying the
values here
but even if we delete these values like
so our number enum here will still have
those values and so we can now assign an
enum as a type as well so let's go ahead
and say we want this to be a nums enum
and we want this to be a nums enum as
well and what we want to do here is just
add those two numbers so what we could
do is let's say we want to call this
function add and we're gonna pass in
nums enum dot num1 and num2
num2 and now we're getting those values
from the enum and if we actually tried
to just pass in a number here which
passed in three I'm surprised that
actually worked because we should be
passing in just an own genome but it
gives you an idea that we should have
that I think if we had a TS lint this
would be a little bit more strict I
think it's being lenient because it's a
number type but what we would get after
we compiled this right so let's go ahead
and we already talked about how to
compile with the TSC command and it's
gonna build it let's go to our example
Jess you also notice that it oh I think
it's doing that for all of our folders
in the area but you'll see here this is
a lot more complicated JavaScript but
for us to get a similar item of what
we've got in our example enum TS right
here which is a very readable
much easier thing to understand this is
actually what we would have had to do to
be able to use it which is kind of crazy
right because I don't know what that's
doing at first glance that's that's
craziness but here it's a little bit
more intuitive right granted
so part of typescript is actually taking
new JavaScript and compiling it to older
versions for so that even though it's
less readable it is more functional it's
not gonna break on bootleg browsers like
Internet Explorer so here you'll see
we'll add these numbers together and if
we're to go ahead and run a quota for
instance on this type share file I'm
gonna save and everything and we consul
blog I don't - out a little bit it
console.log the return of this add
statement you'll see that we get 1
because this is 0 and this is 1 and it's
getting those values from our genome now
if we were to change these values and
here or there it would reflect it
because we're importing this but that's
how we would create a a number he know
now you can also create string enums
these are a newer addition to typescript
one reason you might have this is let's
say that you have a drop-down that's
never gonna change but you want the
values to be all in one location and you
want them to the users gonna select them
and maybe at one day you'll edit them
and you're using various files you could
use an enum for that I've done it with
like country codes and things like that
and currency codes and where I wanted to
keep a list of it so you could all you
have to do here is now set this to a
value this could be like hello and this
could be a goodbye
and now you've created an enum that's
gonna break our code right because well
in our example TS with that s files link
apology but we now have a string enum
that we can reference as well you can
also define local types as well now
there's sort of global types you can
define define and those are more so
called interfaces and we'll showcase
that in a little bit let's say we wanted
to define a type that we're going to
only use in this file could use it at
the type command and we'll just say
we'll call it num num example and this
is going to be equal to an object with a
property and the scene being numb one of
type number and this will be numb two of
type number
now we're not assigning values here
we're defining a type so this is the key
and this is the type of the key there is
no value we are creating a type here
with this type keyword and now instead
of using our enums like we were using
before perhaps we wanted to modify this
to only take in one value and that value
would be we have changes to the nomes
right wanted to reflect what our code is
here where our value would be our num
example and now when we try and target
this value here and we say nums you'll
see then we hit this dot the num1
property and the num2 property type
exists because we've defined it in our
num example type so we can do num num 1
and num stop num two and then of course
we have to go ahead and if we want to
throw a value in here we have to throw a
value in here that makes sense right we
have num1 and then maybe that's 1 and
you'll notice we're still getting here
because we don't have all the values in
here to showcase that but now that we do
and it matches this type everything's
hunky-dory and we're good to go so
that's how we would define a type now as
I mentioned this type here is good only
in this local file now a better way of
defining a type and sometimes in the TS
lint and the standard seems to be to get
away from defining types and more so
defined interfaces so we would do it
like so we'll say num example dot
interface dot TS now this is just a file
naming convention that I typically
follow but we want to export a interface
usually interfaces are denoted with an I
in the name of the class too to let
everyone know that it is a interface
it's not required but we're gonna go
ahead and go with it numbs example so
now that we have that we could go ahead
and pass an object here which is num1
and that's a number and then num2 and
that's a number and you're saying a
gentleness is very similar to what we
were doing just a moment ago with the
type and that is true however
types are declared within the file and
this this ABS a little bit of a
readability issue as well as we want to
keep our code dry we don't want to
repeat ourselves so if there's ever an
instance in which we would need to use
this this interface again this
essentially this type here we can whilst
we can't reuse types so that's one way
one one main difference between
interfaces and types really types
there's essentially being deprecated at
this point in time so I would say stick
with interfaces if you're looking to do
that so there's also well access
modifiers which are an object or
anything that's new to JavaScript as
well because we don't really have them
and they aren't really real in the sense
of like hey this is a development access
modifier it doesn't really matter once
it all compiles down but it's equally as
important and eventually they may come
to exists as static types will
eventually come to exist in JavaScript
in one way or the other so let's say we
have a class here and we'll call this
example dot class TS classes are
something that got added into es6 and we
have a great way of creating classes in
in typescript as well so it's very
similar export class so that we can use
it if we wanted to right and our class
will just call this example class and
we're gonna create some properties by
default if we don't assign anything we
say hey what do we want property let's
say this is a person instead of an
example we'll call this our person class
and what might a person property be I
might have something like a first name
and that might be a string and then we
might have something like a last name
that might be a string and then we might
have something like an age and that will
be a boolean so we've defined our class
here which looks very similar to
interface at this point in time because
we haven't added all the items that a a
class essentially allows us and by
default these are what are called public
properties what public means and you
could put them on here and typically I'd
like to I like to be more descriptive
with my code some people will say I'd
rather just look at the code and be able
to see that that's what it does but
these are public properties that mean
that the user when they're clicking on a
page can access it and that other parts
of the application can access it there's
also things called private properties
private properties and let's say age
will say bank account all right yeah
what nobody wants to share that and this
will be a number this is something that
within your application you can use but
the user who would be consuming the
application the client wouldn't be able
to call this function that's really hit
at the end of the day and so these are
usually functions that other functions
are going to call to hide some of your
code and properties for that matter
there's also protected as well which
essentially means that it's going to be
inherited from another another class in
this case we don't that's the only way
you can access to it I won't worry too
much about that but there is another
great one which I called read which is
read-only so in our case first name and
last name once we set a first name and a
last name is not likely it's going to
change right so we want to have the
read-only access modifier meaning that
once it's set you can't reset this
elsewhere you can't update this
elsewhere in the code because this is a
read-only property it can only be read
it can never be written to so those are
some some t eslint access modifiers and
of course if you're not familiar with
you you know constructors you can pass
in data and set these properties and
your TS link class as well so you would
do something like oh well this stuff
first name is equal to data first name
and then you could create public or you
know public example public functions or
you could create private functions as
well as you know protected so these are
how you might use them on functions as
well so I want to talk about decorators
a little bit these are an experimental
part of JavaScript they eventually may
make their way into it they're currently
in typescript in angular they're used
pretty extensively and I
just wanted to give an example we're not
going to talk about how creating a
decorator and all that sort of stuff
because it gets a little academic when
we go into it and honestly I haven't
found any use cases in my own personal
like vanilla JavaScript where I need to
create a decorator but they are used in
angular so I think it's worth mentioning
so a decorator is usually denoted by
this @ symbol and then this a word in
our case it's the component decorator
and this what the point of this is is it
will normally go before your classes and
it adds some metadata that maybe your
class is going to need to be able to
perform and use and stuff that's not
going to change you know in our case it
adds a selector it adds a place where
this is going to load in the view and
then add some CSS files that are gonna
be with it so you can make a decorator
do about just store about any data they
connect and do things but I wanted to
bring it up we're not gonna create it
again but I think it's worth just
mentioning all right let's talk a little
bit about intersection types just a
little bit more of an advanced thing and
I honestly have never used a look again
hey there's a video where we're trying
to learn so let's add some stuff in here
do use so let's say that we had we
imported our interface that we created
earlier I'm going to go ahead and import
with all this items example from
not slash another example that interface
so what we can do here is we can
actually merge items together merge
types together and one thing to be
careful of is if you are overriding
property values which is why it's
usually frowned upon when you're doing
this but in our example we have a number
one and number two property so let's go
ahead and close that close that jump
back in here and let's change this to
number three and number four so we don't
have any any issues here but what we can
do is let's define a value here and we
can actually create a new type where we
say this type and we'll call this
intersection type intersection is equal
to the items example and the num example
type that we defined as well and what
this is essentially going to do is give
it get combine those two together and
allow us to have those values so when we
go ahead and we type intersection here
it's in Section I guess what it's going
to expect is that we have num 3 and this
is you know throw number in and number 4
and we throw a number in as well so you
can combine types as well although there
found a reason and do it something you
can do just be careful I guess is my
word of caution
now hopefully by now you've kind of seen
the power of typescript and we're gonna
take it one step further we've covered
everything I wanted to cover about
typescript thus far but another thing
that I wanted to talk about is setting
up TS Lynne if you've never used a
linting tool before what it basically is
like Jaya Jaya slant as well is a way to
say hey I want my code to stick to a
standard format and so that there's a
space here this would be a linting error
that's dirty code in that there's no
semi clone here that would be in lint in
there it's dirty code and make sure that
I'm writing code like a developer should
is really the point of a TS lint array
linting option we're gonna go
and get you started so that you can
start writing code that when employers
look at they can see that is of a
professional nature
now again I'm using Visual Studio so
where you can get started to search for
TS lint here you'll see it has four
point seven million downloads it's
probably one of the most used eye items
there is so just go ahead and install
that in the visual studio code to get
going here and we'll talk a little and
we're gonna have to reload and we'll
talk a little bit about what this is
gonna do for us at the end of the day
okay after you have the extension
installed what we're gonna do is we're
in your CTS Lane - - and NIT command to
install okay now that we have the TS Lin
extension install we actually need to
install the TS Lane NPM package globally
so we're just gonna do NPM install - gee
remember how we did - I served in this
case it's gonna be Tia slow so once that
stone installing should just be a second
here we are now going to go ahead and
create a TS lint file using TS lint - -
and knit and you'll see here we jump
back to here we have this TS link json
now what this is basically going to give
us is it's going to have some default
rules and a bunch of other things that
we can override just set what rules we
find important when it comes to our
linting you'll see already when we jump
into some of our files we already have
airs here and it'll tell you when you
hover over it trailing whitespace in
this case it means that we have actually
spaced out manually so spaces here that
the compiler are saying need to exist
and that we don't need that so let's
delete that and then you'll see here
what is this this block is empty there
should be no empty blocks of code right
that shouldn't be a thing so it's
telling us like hey put code here or get
rid of it same thing here we can have
that and we could absolve this by
putting a comment if we need it an empty
block or there's ways to disable TS lint
so you also see like we have a white
space right here this is not clean code
to have these spaces now there's a lot
of TS lint rolls and you can override
them and in some cases you'll see here
like an
all files should end with a a extra line
at the end there's some compiler uses
for that but that's the convention but
you can you can hover over this and
they'll tell you so there's a couple
things that you can do you can do /t
eslint : disable and this will disable
all the TS late
tracking while you're developing from
that line down in this folder so again
you can go and set some custom rules for
your TS lint they're going to have the
recommended ones and that's what I
recommend if you're using typescript you
should probably be using and unless
you're working in a production
environment that has a different
standard for whatever reason what the
language itself recommends it's
Microsoft maintains TS lint it's
Microsoft who makes typescript so that's
my personal opinion but if you did want
to set rules or override rules for your
TS slin this is the the page where you
can go and get all of it and you can see
there are a ton of rules of what you can
modify here and every new iteration of
typescript has additional rules as they
are getting stricter or modifying some
things and and going from there so keep
that in mind when you are working with
typescript that TS lint and if you were
saying look down I didn't sell me on top
security I don't know how I couldn't but
you didn't sell me on the importance of
it but if you're just like I'm sticking
with JavaScript fine that's completely
fine you should probably be doing
linting in your javascript and you can
get ajs lint or Annie s lint package you
can see here is lint has 7.1 million
downloads and it's being used quite
often as well and it works similarly
it's just a little bit of setup so I do
encourage you to do that but as always
guys I hope you enjoyed this video I
hope you found it helpful instructional
and I hope by the end of it you can get
up and get going with typescript I've
actually been loving it for the last
eight nine months I've been working in
it and I plan to continue working